George Clooney issues a dire warning
that pregnant Megan Marco could be
heading toward the same fate as Princess
Diana which is quite a statement but
Clooney pulls no punches as he lashes
out at the media for the way they're
attacking the Duchess George Clooney
wants the paparazzi to leave Megan alone
saying quote she's a woman who is seven
months pregnant and she has been pursued
and vilified and chased in the same way
that Diana waz and its history repeating
itself
the added quote we've seen how that ends
Princess Diana died after a car accident
in a Paris tunnel in 1997 her driver who
was drunk was attempting to shake off
photographers who were pursuing her
Princess Di is dead and who should we
see about that Clooney scolded the
tabloids after Diana's death and a 2007
he blasted the paparazzi for chasing him
on his motorcycle so many walls are
being broken and it's getting to a place
where other people are at risk George
who is friends with Diana's son Prince
Harry attended his wedding to Megan with
his wife Amal last year what makes Harry
and Meghan the perfect couple oh they're
just so happy they're happy and in love
and it's always you know we need good
news tonight in London the royal couple
enjoyed a date night at a museum it
seems as if Megan's every move is
scrutinized she was recently the focus
of a TLC documentary Kate versus Megan
princesses at war why did you choose in
America not a Brit meanwhile George shot
down a rumour that he'll be the
Godfather to making an Aries upcoming
royal baby
Clooney said quote no I'm the father of
twins I have enough blank to deal with
literally George made the comments
yesterday while promoting his new Hulu
series catch-22 but his number one focus
his twins they're a year and a half now
and George told us they pretty much
slept through their first birthday we
had a cake waiting and we'd wake them up
and show it to them and they'd go back
to sleep
[Music]